[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
nursing home industry groups say they're
alarmed by a recent coronavirus spike in
their facilities
federal data shows the number of cases
surged in july
after falling in june that's a problem
since more than one quarter of all
covid related deaths in the u.s are
linked to nursing homes
our lead national correspondent david
begno is in miami beach
good morning david good morning you know
the state of florida continues to lead
in the wrong direction
when it comes to the number of people
dying from the coronavirus
yesterday florida set another record for
the number of deaths reported in a
24-hour period
277. when you talk about nursing homes
it's as relevant in florida as anywhere
else there are nearly
700 nursing homes in this state but we
want to begin this morning with a story
out of idaho
where a woman says her elderly mom was
infected with coronavirus inside the
nursing home
and she didn't find out until right
before her mother died we don't know
when my mom got sick
we don't know how long she was sick that
is caroline fary
she says she had no idea her 90-year-old
mother virginia smith
was receiving end-of-life care until two
days before she died
at her boise idaho nursing home one of
her front-line care workers and aide
had called me on my cell phone
from her private cell phone and she
wanted me to be able to talk to my mom
and i didn't understand what that meant
fari says her mother had a high
fever and had lost a tremendous amount
of weight but that the facility where
she lived
shaw mountain of cascadia had not tested
her for covid19
was she treated for coronavirus no
why not good question when she was
finally tested after the family insisted
the results were positive
miss smith died the next day in july
cases and coveted related deaths in
nursing homes
rose along with cases nationally the
trump administration has said protecting
nursing homes is a priority
at this news conference last month
officials promised to provide tests and
rapid testing instruments
to the nation's more than 15 000 nursing
homes but tuesday the president
delivered a much smaller number
we've delivered over 1 800 rapid
point-of-care testing devices to nursing
homes
we're now getting pretty close to the
same numbers of new cases of nursing
homes that we were experiencing at the
highs in the spring
that is mark parkinson ceo of the
american healthcare association
he says the wait times for tests at
nursing homes can take as long as six
days
making it harder to protect the most
vulnerable like virginia smith
whose daughter is heartbroken over how
her mother
spent her last days it's a callous
disregard for my mother and
and for her right to to have a peaceful
death and a dignified death
she suffered miss virginia smith had 12
grandkids 10 great-grandkids her
daughter said she was a devout catholic
who went to mass nearly
every day for 40 years we reached out to
the nursing home in idaho to try and
address some of the concerns that the
family shared with us
but the nursing home has not responded
to our calls we did see that an attorney
who represents the nursing home that
owns the company
gave a statement to an idaho newspaper
which covered this story and i want to
share with you that
that attorney said the company continues
to follow all applicable guidance from
federal and state health agencies
and works to provide self-care and
mitigate the damage
from covet 19. david thank you very much